hey guys today we're gonna talk about
referred pain now what is referred pain
basically it's pain that is coming from
a different location than you hurt so
for example if you step on a dog's tail
he's gonna bark through his mouth right
you're not gonna mess with the mouth
they'll take the pressure off the tail
but for this video I'm gonna actually
use a volunteer here so Jared thank you
for coming up here all right I tell you
what let's have you stand right there
okay Wow looks like I didn't quite get
that right they're a little off-center
there okay the first thing is the
pancreas the pancreas is an organ
let's see in right through here pancreas
is right underneath the left ribcage
right through here and it comes actually
even crosses over sometimes so it's
right here if you have inflammation in
your pancreas it can be referred to the
left shoulder or the back okay right
through in here or it doesn't
necessarily have to be referred it could
just hurt right over the pancreas right
there now the gallbladder which is the
opposite side right underneath the
ribcage right through in here will
usually refer pain to the shoulder area
right through here there's a little
muscle called the levator angle a
scapula muscle and it's this people will
just kind of want a massage on the right
trap but it's really this tiny little
muscle right through and here that
raises up the shoulder like this and
that's where you'll normally get it so
be a tight not to be painful this is
gallbladder for sure and also be the
what's happening is that there's a
little nerve that goes underneath the
diaphragm okay and that nerve is called
the phrenic nerve and it goes all the
way to the neck the cervical vertebra
like see three four and five so some of
these nerve roots make up something
called the phrenic nerve so you can have
pain in the right side of your neck
right through in here
it can even refer to the right temple
through here and the jaw and cause a
headache on this side pain could be
right through in here okay and you can
even create tension in your neck and
pull out the vertebra to one side and
pinch the nerve and cause pain anywhere
down the right arm I've seen that all
the time even to the fingers right
through
now the liver is right through in here
if the liver is inflamed or congested or
not working that can cause pain also in
the right shoulder but primarily it's
going to be in this muscle right through
in here the rhomboid on the right side
now over here we have the spleen which
is just underneath the ribcage so the
pancreas and the spleen is right here
that can cause pain on the left shoulder
right through in here and the heart is
just off the midline right through in
here and by the way the hearts the size
of your fist and that will cause pain
down the left arm right through here it
can cause pain in the shoulder or even
the jaw on this side now put your finger
on your belly button okay good so his
prostate is right down here that can
refer pain to the back side now if you
had ovaries what will happen is it'll be
just to the left or just to the right of
the of that area right here that will
cause pain in what's called the
sacroiliac joints so the sacroiliac
joints on the right side on the left
side there are little joints that
connect the pelvic bone to the sacrum
right here so to be right here and right
here so if you have pain on the right
side your female that would be the right
ovary paying the left side right here
that could be the left ovary and if
you're a male and you have a prostate
the pain can be right in the lower back
right through in here now there's also
something called sciatica pain and that
is pain that runs down the back of the
leg and go all the way to the lower part
of the foot that's coming from a pinched
nerve either in your back or one of the
muscles in your butt you have several
muscles there and one is called the
piriformis and that can go into a spasm
and tighten up the nerve and cause
sciatic pain on that side sonic pain
usually comes from either a tailbone
injury some injury to the lower back or
prolonged sitting where you lose the
curve of your lower back in which case
you need to actually put that curve back
in and the last organ we're talking
about is the kidney okay so the kidneys
are located here in here okay and the
kind of the upper abdomen deep inside so
in the back if you have 12 vertebra
right through in here and you have the
12th rib the kidneys are like just right
underneath that right here
and right here so if there's a problem
with the kidney whether it's a kidney
stone or inflammation your kidney you
can have pain anywhere
underneath the last 12th rib to the
spine it's this little triangle right
here somewhere in the upper back on this
side or this side right here now if
there's a kidney stone that dislodges
from either kidney that goes down to
through the little tube called the
ureter on its way to the bladder this
would cause pain in the groin area so
the problem is not in the groin it's
actually in the ureter that little tube
there now the thing to know about
referred pain is they don't know a lot
about what causes referred pain where it
could be some type of problem with the
nerve circuitry or some soft tissue
whether it be fossa or ligament or a
tendon or muscle so the next point I
want to talk about is what percentage of
the population has referred pain versus
pain that actually is coming from the
actual pain source so the answer to that
is it's a large percentage I would guess
to say that 50 60 percent of the pain
that an average person has is referred
from another area of the body especially
if you hadn't had any injury at all to
an area and you start hurting for no
reason then suspect it could be referred
now there's a couple of foundational
things that you need to do if you have
referred pain obviously involves an
organ and that organ usually has a
problem because the person's diet is not
good so you can treat this area over and
over and over and even get rid of the
pain but it's gonna keep coming back
until you fix the diet now if you're not
new to my channel you know what the
solution is but if you are someone that
is new to the channel there's two things
you need to do healthy keto and in a
minute fasting both of these actions
together can help clean up these organs
and actually help to give them a rest
because you're going to be doing in a
minute fasting and you're going to find
the inflammation is going to go way down
the organ is going to eventually heal
and you're going to be out of pain now
as far as myself I
head right shoulder pain for 12 years
and I did not make the connection
between my gallbladder and this right
shoulder I would get massages I would
get chiropractic treatments and it would
last for a nanosecond and it kept coming
back little did I know it was related to
my diet and after I eventually found you
know in a minute fasting and did that
I've had absolutely no pain in that
right shoulder for years but usually the
person will swear it was from an old
injury that they had and that's what's
responsible for it but it's really
related to their diet so if you're not
on healthy keto and in a minute fasting
do yourself a favor and try it and see
how much it can help you and the very
last thing I want to say is that if you
go to a practitioner and you get treated
and you need repeated treatments over
and over and over for months and months
and months suspect that there is this
situation going on in your body and
isolate the area that you have focus on
that and ignore this because this is the
symptom this is the cause all right
thanks for watching and if you haven't
already subscribed click the red button
below and that little bell icon so you
can be notified of all the new videos
that I'm gonna be releasing and I have
some very cool and interesting videos
coming up in the next coming weeks plus
in addition to that you'll be notified
of the live Q&A sessions that I'm going
to be doing throughout the week and you
don't want to miss those as well so stay
tuned for more great content